well first of all I love pilot or the
first episode thank you so much and tell
me why what drew you so I first read the
book that Simon wrote what in God's name
which the series is based on a few years
ago and I was immediately just like
sucked into the world of it and the
humor but also just the kind of the fact
that this book managed to have this like
be very very dark and also very very
funny I kind of have this built this
beautiful world that I always think like
you know that's one of the things in
great literature where you just want to
spend kind of irrelevant to the story
you just want to spend time in the world
finding out how it all works and so I I
read the book and I loved it and then
I've got to meet Simon and basically
said you know if you ever make anything
of this please I will be happy to be
enrolled in any capacity that you'll
have me and like a year later Simon
phoned me up with the idea of doing it
to a TV series and then I read the
scripts and it was just yeah I was a new
dream yeah so right away you you work
with them yeah the moment that Dan said
that he was on board was the first time
it kind of occurred to me that we might
have a chance of successfully adapting
it from the page to the screen and
obviously when he mentioned that he had
joined the book I immediately was like
if he could play Craig we might be able
to pull it off and it's been it's been
so much fun working together the last
few years and it's exciting to to see it
out in the world now ya know I gotta say
when I it was not what I expected okay
watched it I went that's not really how
I picture no I mean I don't I don't
picture an afterlife but I also I mean I
it it fits with how you know I feel like
you you want to you know the great thing
why the reasons we've seen is sort of a
lot of comedies involving heaven or God
are they is that everyone has a everyone
has something they picked her even if
you are sort of about vaguely agnostic
you know you have something you're
imagining if you think about God or or a
heaven so everyone has a set of
expectations that you can kind of
subvert and have fun with by by you know
being the opposite of them for most of
us and I mean well obviously you've
created it so is that in a way I was
like oh my god it's a kind of
corporation yeah it's a it's a really in
our show God played by Steve Buscemi is
the founder and CEO of heaven Inc which
is the giant corporation in the sky that
runs earth and it's just a horrible mess
of a corporation it's an industrial
Factory in the clouds where everything
is falling apart and there's peeling
paint and accidents happen all the time
and there are budget cuts and certain
departments are underfunded and so on on
the surface it sounds like a very dark
nihilistic cynical sad show but there's
a few employees a few angels low ranking
angels at Heaven Inc including the one
played by Dan Craig and the department
of answered prayers who really want to
do something positive even though the
system is so flawed and it's a show
about a bunch of individuals who get
together and decide to try to do
something good even though the system is
very very bad I kind of got the sense
that there might be a romance in the
upcoming episode I mean I think that
it's it's I think a lot I think
Eliza comes into Craig's world and Craig
has not seen another human being who has
been this friendly with him in a long
time I don't think if you asked Craig he
would fully be able to tell you the
difference between how much he likes her
or being in love with her or being
terrified of her being in all of her I
think this is a combination of all of
those things and he doesn't quite know
what feeling that manifests itself in in
him to me the biggest thing of the
series is is is will he is less do they
go out than will Craig have the guts to
even broach the subject with her or even
that it's late because I I don't know I
haven't told Carol about this but like I
feel it's pretty one-way like
here like she's kind of blissfully
unaware the Craig is dealing with any of
this and he is just like not quite
knowing what to make of her because he's
feeling so many things right exactly
he's a very emotionally guarded and
stunted character when we meet him and
you know his his journey is is one of
going from a place of total isolation
not speaking to anybody having no
friends being a terrified in socializing
to learning how to step outside that
comfort zone and find a community yeah
and it's it's hard work because when we
meet him he's pretty pretty far gone
yeah you know at his work desk
essentially for literally thousands of
years so I you know one of the miracles
of the show is that he ends up actually
having friends you never would expect
when you first meet him no they said
what they loved about working with you
is that you still have a love for acting
and for coming to work every day so you
tell me about that yeah I mean I've got
the best job in the world we all do like
if you if you are on a film set even on
the worst day you've won the lottery
like is there are so many people out
there that would love to be where you
are and yeah I will never I understand
actors who who seem to like go out of
their way to make it less pleasant and
that for everyone so yeah I do I mean
the right I did I love I love doing it
like a lot being on set yes yeah yeah I
was I was lucky enough to be like
involved very early on with this with
this show and particularly in casting
like I really and that that was probably
the the part of that process I enjoyed
the most was getting to see all these
tapes from amazing amazing actors and
then suddenly getting to see one that
just like did found something or did
something that nobody else had done it
was just a yeah it was very exciting I
think I probably never had more respect
for actors than when you see so many of
them doing you know what what a how you
can stand out any great audition or yeah
okay I was reading this little tidbit
about you okay you watch The Bachelor oh
yes yeah yeah voraciously so I know yeah
hurry this up yeah I am I watching here
tonight so yeah my girlfriend's back in
New York now so we have a Skype date so
she's gonna record it then press we're
gonna try and wrist play at the same
time so we like sync up through the
adverts cuz she were on three-hour delay
but yeah I'm into The Bachelor it's it's
just an insane television program but
it's why I think I like it because it
does just seem like some crazy human
experiment which people have let
themselves become a part of but also
like yeah I mean I it's it's a very
watchable child do you think I've gone
for Cassie this year but like I've said
that she's gonna get booted off tonight
now that I've said this but yeah that's
my that's my pick well I loved the pilot
or the first episode I know it's an
anthology so so you're coming back in
and I'm holed Oh what are some
potentials for next season I too early
to talk about but we wait to it yeah
we're excited about it it's a definitely
an another big swing you know if we are
lucky enough to get a second series I
like to think that like them the
majority of us would be back yeah
definitely but it feels just so early
last thing having these conversations
about series who freaks me out because
I'm just like wait we're not there yeah
well let's see people like the first
yeah yeah but regardless we feel so
lucky to have had a chance to do this
story and tell it all the way through
you know that's the you don't always get
a chance in television to write a finale
sometimes you know a show just
disappears and that's that's actually
the norm which is bizarre I mean imagine
as you know as a imagine I came in if
most films intended 70 or 80 percent of
the way through via tragedy yeah you
know and that is how it is with
television and so we feel so fortunate
as producers that we were able to finish
the story and write the end at the last
episode lastly a lot of times people
when God is
- oh yeah there can be some groups that
jump on it right are you prepared you
what do you save in those groups that
might write Oh have some backlash or
yeah I mean I would say give it a chance
like don't hate us till you've watched
us home but also you know I think there
will be some people who like so you
can't make jokes about even saying that
even if we can say all we like that our
God is not the God that it's in the
Bible order but some people will just
never be pleased with jokes about God
but I don't think what you're probably
ever gonna win those people over I can
get such a love for Humanity and for
God's creations in this show if you
believe in God then that there is still
like it's a kind channel also due to the
fact that God is a character in it we
none of us could use oh my god as an
expletive so it's arguably the least
blasphemous show on television it's true
we never say his name in vain no yeah
it's a it's a show that is ultimately
pro-earth
you know at the show that basically says
that you know the planet is good the
planets worth saving and yeah it's a
show that says the vast majority of
events happened randomly and horribly
all the time and there's no logic behind
any of it and no grand design but it's
also a show that says that miracles are
possible and happen every day so I hope
that that uh people who have faith would
be willing to stand said at least check
it out yeah at least the first like 2
episodes yeah it's super Shammi isn't me
just asking you know want him to be good
I mean that would be the best thing in
the world if you shown over there it was
you